you hear to save myself I understand
it's your birthday yeah the party's just
getting started
his name is Kellerman we've traced his
bloodline back 500 years to the
Assassin's Creed Cal has anyone in the
world knows or cares you no longer exist
this is your second chance
what do you work for me your past you're
about to enter the Animus what you see
hear and feel are the memories of your
ancestor who's been dead for 500 years
wait a minute
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
so on their and family
it was
you're watching you waiting to see who
you are
I believe you are destined for great
things that's fine now yes
and work in the dark to set up the
lights
we are assassins
I'm beginning to like this
who traced his bloodline back 500 years
his name's calamar you me your past
rather mana limited my mom everything's
permitted we work in the dark
to serve the light
we are assassins Assassin's Creed at
pg-13 SAS ins and Templars have been at
war of essentials the assassins believe
that above all else mankind should have
free will the tempers are more
interested in power and a way to control
the human race full of bloodlines
the assassins died on bar one his name
is Callan Minj
what do you work for me your past
assassins are making sure that freedom
is still protective in cherished tempers
want us all dead in your hands now
in the dark sort of the light we are
assassins
the concept of assassins and Templars
battling through the centuries as a
fantastic cinematic experience its
original and inventive
what you're about to see hear and feel
are the memories of your ancestor and
has been dead for 500 years your past
Cal you're an assassin
I'm beginning to like that
the party's just getting started with
pg-13 what you're about to see hear and
feel are the memories of your ancestor
who has been dead for 500 years what do
you want from me you're past the
Assassin's Creed universe just seemed
like something that would lend itself
very nicely to a cinematic experience
we're really determined to make an
audience believe that this world and
these characters exists to have somebody
with Justin's strength and vision was a
huge bonus I want it to be an
unbelievable ride mixed with these
exotic worlds that then lead you into
some action sequences that are dynamic
in an era where there's a lot of CGI we
wanted to have as much old-school real
location shoots as possible so Spain
becomes a huge part of our film and
exoticness of the assassins
when you put on the costume you really
feel like the character
in terms of the fighting for Aguilar his
weapon of choice with the blades on the
wrist
we're very important for us to get the
parkour element you know the fans are
going to be looking for those he's going
to be really exciting
we are making the new music experience
the work in the dark just turn up the
light
we are assassins
we work in the dark certain light hey
guys I'm gonna shoot we are assassins
the film with Assassin's Creed I just
want it to be an unbelievable ride that
leads you into some action sequences
that are dynamic and they feel really
exciting and we're trying to base as
much as possible in reality
I'm de volta system Tabuk Michel in the
movie Michael Fassbender's character is
trapped and he has to jump the leap of
faith jumping 125 feet normally it would
be a digital character that would jump
off Damien's the best so we're going to
do it for real
Justin wants it to be as real as
possible we're going to the real world
we're not relying on visual effects we
start off low with the first jump is
just a matter of figuring out the timing
of the freefall the actual footprint in
the bag is only 10 meters by 10 meters
so when you're up there it looks about
size of a four piece paper we've
inverted jump seven feet
drop again
in the bag top-heavy so get a bit with
much on the back of the head so I try
and not do that three two
that's the best bit when you walk off
and go I'm alright yeah
the assassins are fighting for free will
and their main rivals are Templars and
Templars are trying to enhance humankind
through science
I think Assassin's Creed has a really
deep concept an idea which is going back
into time and having some sort of
relationship with the ancestor that's
come before you the overall journey of
the film is through the eyes of our
protagonist so the Michael Fassbender is
playing your past
he starts to learn that he comes from a
lineage of assassins he realizes the
true history of himself and he creates a
kind of revolution
something right
we are assassins
michael is one of the greatest actors of
his generation and there's many other
strong characters in the film
the Assassin's Creed universe is a
cinematic experience action sequences
are massive
I just want it to be an unbelievable
ride have to show him who he really is
mine at 6:00 p.m. yesterday evening you
were executed and pronounced dead you no
longer exist what kind of person is this
it's not a prison you're about to enter
the Animus what you're about to see hear
and feel are the memories of your
ancestor who has been dead for 500 years
what do you want from me your past
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition I am
God even though I'm a man of God Oh
we work in the dark just sort of the
light we are assassins
you
you were executed and pronounced dead
you no longer exist
what kind of prison is this it's not a
prison you're about to enter the Animus
what you're about to see hear and feel
are the memories of your ancestor who
has been dead for 500 years what do you
want from me your past
welcome to the Spanish Inquisition
we work in the dark just sort of the
light we are assassins
oh this rock
Charlie's son of mine I can't so this is
where you come every Saturday instead of
practice